Professor David Blight:
It used to be said that in
the old wars fought by the Irish
clans that they had an
agreement.
I don't know if this is true,
but I love the idea,
that no matter how much they
slaughter themselves with
broadswords and knives and
whatever else those maniacs
used,
that they should always spare
the poets.
Don't kill the poets,
because the poets had to be
left to tell the story.
Most great poets don't go to
war, they write.
This week you're reading a
great poet, E.L.
Doctorow, a poet in prose,
a poet in fiction.
Doctorow, as some of you must
know, is a famous American
writer for his historical
fiction.
Much of his fiction is often
very historical and you'll find,
if anyone takes the time some
day,
that large chunks of the
monologue you hear from William
Tecumseh Sherman in this novel
is directly out of his famous
memoirs,
and then every now and then
Doctorow will embellish or add a
few lines.
Most of the people in this book
were real people,
but there are some invented.
In some ways,
possibly the most brilliant
inventions in this book are the
slave characters,
or the freedman characters,
and what Doctorow does with
them through this sort of
anguished crucible of all out
war.
Look especially for those
journeys into Sherman's own
mind, Sherman's psyche,
those meditations of Sherman's
on death.
Page 88 and 89 to be exact is,
I think, an unforgettable
mediation by Sherman on the
meaning of death and just what
it means and why he in some ways
enjoys it.
Herman Melville wrote a whole
bunch of poems during the Civil
War.
He was one of the poets spared.
He wasn't very famous yet,
as you know,
for Moby Dick;
that was to come later.
Maybe our greatest writer of
the nineteenth century;
also wrote a lot of poetry,
and he wrote almost all of his
poetry during the Civil War,
as did, by the way,
Emily Dickinson.
Don't know if any of you are
Emily Dickinson fans,
but Emily, the Belle of
Amherst,
wrote between 900 and 1000
poems in her life,
and fully two-thirds of them in
the four years of the war.
She became obsessed with the
idea of the war,
and if you read her closely
enough it's all over her wartime
poetry.
She became obsessed with death.
Our greatest death poet was,
of course, Whitman;
more from him later.
But one little piece by
Melville, because it's about
you.
This was Melville's meditation
in poetry on the death of
college students in the war.
It's called "On the Slain
Collegians."
It's timeless,
it could be about any war,
although collegians don't go to
war anymore very much in
America.
"Youth is the time when hearts
are large and stirring wars
appeal to the spirit which
appeals in turn to the blade it
draws.
If woman in sight and duties
show, though made the mask of
Cane, or whether it be truth,
sacred cause,
who can aloof remain that
shares youth's ardor,
uncooled by the snow of wisdom
or sordid gain?
Woe for the homes of the North
and woe for the seats of the
South, all who felt life spring
in prime and were swept by the
wind of their place in time.
Oh lavish hearts on whichever
side of birth or bane or courage
high, arm them for the stirring
wars, arm them some to die,
Apollo-like in pride.
Each slay his python caught,
the maxims in his temple
taught.
The anguish of maternal hearts
must search for balm divine.
But well the striplings bore
their faded parts,
the heaven all parts must
assign.
Never felt life's care or cloy.
Each bloomed and died an abated
boy, nor dreamed what death was,
thought it mere sliding into
some vernal sphere.
They knew the joy but leaped
the grief.
Like plants that flower 'ere
comes the leaf which storms lay
low in kindly doom and kill them
in the flush of their bloom."
The casualties in the Union
Army alone, the Army of the
Potomac, Grant's army,
from the first of May through
the end of July 1864,
in this horrible war of
attrition and the stalemate it
produced in Virginia,
the casualties in that one army
in about two to two-and-a-half
months was 66,000 men.
It is the largest loss of life
in the shortest period of time
in all of American military
history.
How did it get to that?
Why did the war go on,
and on and on?
Well let's begin with Grant and
Lee, these two great warriors
around whose names,
symbols, actions,
decisions a good deal of the
war would hinge in the final
year.
Grant, from his successes in
the West--fall of Vicksburg,
siege and fall of Chattanooga,
the victory at
Chickamauga--came East,
appointed by Abraham Lincoln as
General of the Army.
Congress actually revived a
special rank that it hadn't used
in years called
Lieutenant-General,
just for Grant.
He came East and was appointed
head of all Union Armies,
on any front anywhere,
in March of 1864,
winter '64.
He was wined and dined at the
White House and wined and dined
in Congress.
They had to keep telling him to
put on a decent uniform.
There's a lot of truth to this
idea of Grant the kind of humble
plebian.
He had after all been doing
nothing but work in his
brother's leather shop in
Galena, Illinois when the war
broke out.
But, boy, did he have a nose
for war.
He was a great horseman.
They said he could canter like
nobody else and gallop like
nobody else, and he loved his
horses.
Been to West Point.
About the only thing he really
got good grades in at West Point
were painting and drawing.
He nearly failed some of the
military science courses.
Some of his biographers have
actually made a big deal out of
that, that because he hadn't
studied hard in Jomini's
Manuals,
those manuals of combat tactics
and strategy,
that he was therefore freer to
simply invent as he went.
I don't know.
This war made Grant at the same
time he made the war.
He may have been,
as many of his--and by the way
there's been an industry of
Grant biographies in the past 10
to 15 years;
he's been rediscovered after a
long period in our history when
he just vanished and the country
forgot that "oh,
by the way, the Union won the
war and there was that guy
Grant."
There are far,
far, far more monuments to
Robert E.
Lee on the American landscape
than there are to Ulysses Grant.
I'll try to explain that at the
end of the course.
His casualty rates in this last
year of the war were ghastly and
horrible, and it nearly led to a
sufficient level of war
weariness across the North and
disgust and just an overwhelmed
kind of spirit that it was
entirely possible by July and
August of '64,
if certain events hadn't
quickly followed,
that the North collectively
would've given up the war and
sued for peace.
But Grant developed essentially
a strategy of victory,
and here's what it was.
He did it in conjunction with
William Tecumseh Sherman,
Philip Sheridan,
the previous General of the
Army,
Henry Halleck,
and most importantly with
Lincoln himself,
and that strategy was basically
this.
It was first to determine that
Richmond, the capital of the
Confederacy, was not to be the
objective of the war in the
East;
taking an enemy's capital not
that important.
Secondly, Grant grasped,
as did Sherman,
the political character of this
war, that this was now a war to
be won or lost in public
opinion.
Because it had become all-out,
because it was now a war upon
people, upon resources,
it depended deeply upon morale
and the will of either side to
somehow see it through.
Third, Grant,
and Sherman especially,
determined that this would now
be a war on Southern resources.
The destruction of slavery,
of course, becomes a major part
of that.
And one of the great ironies of
the war is that Sherman never,
ever, for a day,
wanted to free a slave.
As he told his officers,
"ain't gonna be no niggers in
Uncle Billy's army."
Sorry, that's what he said.
He wasn't into having black
soldiers;
in fact there were no black
soldiers who actually served in
Sherman's army in Georgia.
There will be thousands upon
thousands of freedman following
his army, and it will force him
to a situation of a recognition
that will it or not,
he's crushing the spirit of the
South to destroy slavery,
and ultimately kind of admits
it.
Look for that in Doctorow.
In the East the object of the
war now was to be Lee's army,
to fight Lee's army anywhere,
on ground especially,
that the Northern troops could
somehow choose to try to spring
Lee out of his trench works,
that he would build everywhere
they would stop,
and to simply kill as many
Confederates as possible to
force the South to quit.
It was to be a war on an army,
not for a strategic capital.
Now strategic crossroads and
rivers and so on would be
important, but the object now
was to destroy the fighting
force of the South and its
fighting will.
And in the Western part of the
war--and there were actually
five major armies now that Grant
was to try to coordinate;
an army under Nathaniel Banks
out in the far west that Lincoln
wanted to go into Texas with,
and they never really got into
Texas.
What Grant wanted
eventually--excuse me one
second--what Grant wanted was
the army under Nathaniel Banks
in Louisiana to move east,
to take Mobile,
the last remaining great
southern port and then come
smashing right through the Deep
South across Alabama into
Georgia,
as Sherman's army,
as we'll see in a minute,
was invading northern Georgia,
toward Atlanta,
and sort of just invade the
whole middle heartland of the
South until the South would give
up.
And in Virginia,
Grant took battlefield command.
He didn't have to,
he could've stayed at his desk
in Washington,
but it was quite decidedly not
his style;
he went into the field as the
Commander of the Army of the
Potomac.
Now, on the other side,
in Robert E.
Lee, the South had without a
question--we've said this before
and there's so much been written
on this you can't count it
all--the South had a great
general in Lee,
a daring general.
In spite of his tremendous
defeat at Gettysburg,
where he actually did tender
his resignation that Davis
didn't accept and couldn't
accept,
Lee was already a legend.
His men saw him as almost
God-like.
He was beautiful,
they said, he was gorgeous,
he was handsome.
No one ever looked quite like
Lee in a uniform with that curly
white hair.
There's a brand new biography
out that I recently reviewed by
a woman named Elizabeth Pryor;
it's just won the Abraham
Lincoln Prize.
There's another lovely irony,
a book on Lee wins the Lincoln
Prize;
that's reconciliation.
[Laughter]
It's called Reading the
Man.
Sounds like a title of a porn
movie or something
but--[Laughter]
Sorry, scratch that Jude.
[Laughter]
But she did the book from Lee's
voluminous letters.
He was a tremendous letter
writer, throughout his life.
Lifetime officer,
son of Light Horse Harry Lee of
the American Revolution fame.
His father had been a total
scoundrel.
He had a brother that was an
even greater scoundrel.
His brother,
and probably his father,
had fathered children by slave
women, had abandoned their
homes, their wives,
their families.
He came from a very,
very difficult,
sordid but aristocratic,
famous Virginia family,
and he went to West Point just
like his daddy,
and he became an officer in his
early twenties.
He spent his twenties,
his thirties,
and his forties spread all over
the United States,
largely as an engineer.
He was a great engineer.
He helped build the first
bridge across the Mississippi.
He helped redirect rivers in
the lower Mississippi,
and on and on.
He spent probably two-thirds of
his life, up until the Civil
War, away from home,
away from that mansion that
sits today in Arlington
Cemetery.
Arlington House was Lee's home.
He inherited it by marrying
into it.
He married a Custis;
he married into the family of
George Washington,
the extended family of George
Washington.
And, of course,
it is Lee's own home,
Arlington, that before the war
even ended the United States
Government confiscated.
Lee's wife, to say the least,
never got over this.
They confiscated Lee's home and
converted it into the largest
national cemetery in the
country.
If you ever go to Arlington,
go to Arlington House,
or at least remember that that
was founded to bury the
thousands and thousands of Union
dead killed by Lee's army.
At any rate,
he may have hated war in the
abstract but his biographers
have taken us into Lee's psyche
in some useful ways.
I won't cite all these many
biographies but some of them
have really shown us a
complicated man of great daring
and audacity and aggressiveness.
He always wanted to be on the
offensive.
He hated being entrenched.
He hated being on the defensive
and he clearly saw war as an
emotional or psychological
release.
"I think a little lead properly
taken is good for a man," he
said.
That was in the Mexican War.
He didn't say that during the
Civil War.
Surveying the field of
slaughter at Fredericksburg in
December of '62 he said,
famously, "It is well that war
is so terrible so that we do not
grow too fond of it."
He appeared to change in battle.
His eyes would be like fire,
people said.
An English journalist observer
in the Battle of the Wilderness,
a horrible battle fought in
dense woods, observed this of
Lee.
"No man who at the terrible
moment saw his flashing eyes and
sternly set lips is ever likely
to forget them,
the light of battle still
flaming in his eyes."
And there are lots of people
who said that about him.
The debate about Lee is
essentially, among historians at
least, is essentially whether he
bled the South to death,
so to speak,
with his aggressiveness,
his two major invasions of the
North and the cost that meant to
the Confederacy,
or whether he was the true
military genius of American
history and only through that
offensive daring did the
Confederacy survive as long as
it did.
Or, only through his devotion
and his maneuverability of huge
numbers of men across difficult
landscapes did the Confederacy
survive as long as it did
through 1864 in his struggle
against Grant's Army,
which outnumbered him at times
two to one, in 1864 and 1865.
But he hated being on the
defensive now in 1864.
"I will strike that man a blow
in the morning,
I will strike that man a blow
in the morning,"
he would say sometimes at night
in his camp, even if he wasn't
planning to do it.
Now, the Campaign of 1864,
the pivotal--in so many ways,
decisive, despite the fact that
it becomes a horrible
stalemate--the decisive campaign
of the Civil War in everyone's
hopes in the North,
a campaign once again that
would only be one summer,
was launched in April and May
of '64.
But it wasn't going to end that
summer.
It would end in a horrible
stalemate and a siege of the
city of Petersburg,
just south of Richmond.
And the war,
of course, would not end until
the following spring,
four Aprils into the war.
But here's roughly what
happened--and by the way I refer
you here to the Ken Burns film
series,
and there's of course a very
good reason that Burns decided
in this nine-part film series to
give two whole parts to the year
1864.
I have my own little criticisms
of that film series which I'll
be happy to share with you at
some point,
but I thought it was actually
quite brilliant the way he just
makes you agonize to get out of
1864;
I mean, God how long must 1864
last?
Because that's actually the way
the country felt.
In the Battle of the
Wilderness, May 5-6,1864,
the two armies basically
collided just west of
Fredericksburg in a densely,
densely wooded area that was
known at that time as the
Wilderness.
They essentially just bumped
into one another because there
were only two roads that went
North, South or East or West
through this area.
And they fought it out in woods
for two days.
It was a totally disorganized
battle.
Often men would only fire at
what they saw other weapons
firing, because they could
really never see their enemies,
and hence sometimes killed
their own men.
And the most horrible thing
about the Wilderness,
of course, as you perhaps have
heard,
is that hundreds,
if not thousands,
of wounded ended up being
burned to death in the woods
because the woods caught on fire
in several places and the
wounded could not be retrieved.
Soldiers on both sides laid
down at night in makeshift
trench works along roadways and
listened to their comrades
scream as they were burning to
death in the woods and could not
save them.
In two days of a really
thoroughly disorganized slugfest
in woods, Grant's Army lost
18,400 casualties,
dead and wounded.
Lee lost about 11,000,
And it appeared that Lee had
once again--for what,
the fourth time now?-- stopped
a Union Army invading into
Virginia,
and that that Union Army would
probably have to retreat back
out of this densely wooded
wilderness,
get up north of the
Rappahannock,
regroup again,
again, again,
as the Army of the Potomac
always had.
And yet what happened was,
of course, Grant never intended
to stop no matter what happened.
He had the obvious advantage of
manpower.
He had tremendous resources
behind him.
Although that manpower was
risky, because that very summer
the three-year enlist--they
weren't up by May but they were
going to be up in June--the
three-year enlistments,
from '61 to '64,
the great mass of the Army of
the Potomac had been in--those
who had survived,
the veterans,
the real soldiers--had been in
for three years and their terms
would be up.
How in the hell to get these
men to re-enlist when they were
enduring this?
And the government came up with
three and four-hundred dollar
bounties, they came up with
thirty day furloughs here and
there,
percentages of regiments sent
home.
They'd do anything to get these
guys to re-enlist.
And Lincoln called for 500,000
more volunteers,
a half a million.
Now they will actually
eventually get almost that half
million men, but the problem,
as the Union armies realized
that summer, is that these new
soldiers, brought in by being
paid bounties and all sort of
other things,
were terrible soldiers.
And Grant counted by July and
August of these new recruits
that about three of every four
became deserters the first time
they faced combat.
So that manpower was not a
certain thing,
but Grant just kept moving.
And there's a famous story.
It's the night of the second
day, it's the 6^(th) of May '64,
and most of the Union Army is
camped along a roadway,
a North/South roadway.
They've just fought the two
worst days of the war,
if they've survived.
They're depleted.
Woods are burning.
They expect any moment to all
have to retreat north.
And there came Grant with just
a few members of his staff
cantering down the road,
heading south.
He didn't stop to say anything
to anybody.
He didn't even tip his hat;
probably spit from his cigar.
And as they saw him moving
South, they began to realize
they weren't retreating.
And for about a mile and a half
along this roadway these scarred
soldiers started to get up and
scream and holler,
at the top of their lungs,
for Grant, for Grant;
they were going South.
And they did.
The rest of this terrible
campaign would be an attempt by
Grant now to outmaneuver Lee,
to try to keep moving left,
Grant's left,
to try to get around Lee's
army, to move faster than Lee,
if possible,
and ultimately to cut off Lee's
supply line, either to Richmond
or further south from Richmond,
and if possible--forget about
taking Richmond--but to try to
cut off Lee's army from the rest
of the South,
and if possible with Sheridan's
army in the Shenandoah Valley
cut him off from the West.
So when Grant gets accused of
being a butcher that summer,
there's some truth to that.
But it really was a war of
maneuver, maneuver,
maneuver.
They collided--actually the
first attempt was to see who
could get first to this
crossroads called Spotsylvania
Courthouse,
and at Spotsylvania they fought
for about six,
seven consecutive days.
This was the rehearsal for
World War One.
Everywhere the army stopped
they dug the deepest possible
trenches they could.
And at Spotsylvania,
indeed, Lee's army got there
just before Grant's army and
they built this incredible
trench work that was in a
U-shape,
and for about six days Grant's
army just made one frontal
assault on this after another,
and it produced these
horrifying scenes of the dead
and wounded, three and four
deep,
in these trenches,
day after day after day,
most of it fought in
rainstorms.
At Spotsylvania,
when you add it all up--they
first encountered each other on
the 8^(th) of May and they
didn't really stop fighting
there until about the 19^(th) of
May--Grant's army lost almost
30,000 casualties;
Lee's army almost 20,000
casualties.
And yet Grant just kept moving
and kept moving,
left and south,
left and south.
And then Grant,
the first week of June,
would make his greatest mistake
of the war, and he admitted it.
It's the only place in his
great two-volume memoir when he
used the word regret,
and he really regretted Cold
Harbor.
At Cold Harbor,
Grant had misinformation.
He somehow did not understand
how much of Lee's army had
actually concentrated in front
of him and somehow he mis-saw
the landscape.
He didn't realize that Lee's
army on each flank had a river,
and those rivers were pretty
high, it was May/June,
and there was no way to flank
him.
So he just made,
on the 3^(rd) of June,
the largest frontal assault
attack of the war.
There were 50,000 Union troops
engaged in this,
and Grant's army took 7000
casualties in a half-hour.
And many of the men--and they'd
been fighting now day after day
after day, and God only knows
what fatalists soldiers become
in that circumstance.
They were asked before the
attack at Cold Harbor to pin
their names and home addresses
on their shirts,
at least much of the Union Army
was.
And they did.
They had no dog tags in that
war.
They were told to pin their
names on themselves so they
could be identified when dead.
And I believe Burns uses this
story in the film.
There was one Union soldier who
etched into his diary,
"Morning, June 3^(rd),
I died today at Cold Harbor."
And he did.
This stopped Grant's movement.
It protected Richmond.
It meant that the war would now
go on and on through that
summer.
Rather than attempting any more
assaults on Lee's forces,
which were now constantly
digging trenches,
all around the eastern side of
Richmond,
Grant kept moving south.
And this time he got to
Petersburg faster than Lee,
or at least most of Lee's army,
and by mid to late June they
put the city of Petersburg,
just some twenty-five miles
south of Richmond,
under siege.
And Petersburg would--and you
can see many of these great
photographs in Burns' film
series.
Photographers went crazy in '64
and '65 photographing these
giant trench works,
these trench cities that were
built around Petersburg.
There would be a quick attempt
to break the siege at Petersburg
in what is known as the Battle
of the Crater--quick in the
sense of about a month after.
Grant's army concentrated all
around the east side and the
south side of Petersburg.
They were always trying to cut
Lee's supply lines off,
either west or south,
and never managed to completely
do it until the next spring.
But you may know the story of
the Battle of the Crater.
Some coalminers in the 48^(th)
Pennsylvania went to their
Colonel, who went to his
General,
who went to General Burnside,
who went to Grant and said,
"We can dig a tunnel,
500 yards, under the
Confederate line,
and we'll fill it with tons of
dynamite,
and we can do it with
ventilation slats,
we know how to do these things,
and we'll blow the Confederate
line to smithereens.
Let us do it."
And at first Grant and his
staff said, "No,
no, no, no, this is too crazy."
They sat down with him,
they convinced him they could
do it, and they did it.
Five hundred yards of a tunnel,
they ventilated it,
the Confederates on the other
side.
And the lines in some areas
here were never more than 150 to
200 yards apart.
They actually did hear some
digging, we're told later,
but they didn't know what the
hell it was.
And then they dug a
counter-trench at the end,
inside, or a tunnel.
They put in four tons of
dynamite, fuses.
You to this day can see the
openings of that tunnel and you
can still see the suppression in
the landscape where the crater
was.
And on July 30,1864 they blew
it up, and they blew up an area
of the Confederate line about
200 yards long.
Men's bodies were simply
exploded into the air.
It's the opening scene of
Cold Mountain,
if you've seen the movie.
Not bad, it's one of the best
parts of that movie actually.
I thought Nicole Kidman was
badly cast;
I don't know about you.
[Laughter]
When you're suffering and you
haven't got enough to eat and
you're laying in the snow you
can't look like Nicole Kidman,
I'm sorry.
[Laughter] It ain't right.
But the problem was the Battle
of the Crater became a Union
disaster.
Instead of exploiting this as
they should have,
and been far,
far more organized--they
should've managed to get around
this crater--actually they
didn't even understand how big
this gigantic hole in the ground
would be--a huge hole in the
Confederate line had been
exploded,
hundreds of yards wide.
But Union troops started
marching into the hole--I'm not
kidding--and within an hour or
two,
as Confederates regrouped,
in sheer shock,
they said it was just like
picking out fish in a bowl,
and they stood all around this
giant hole in the ground.
And 4,000 Union troops were
killed in the Battle of the
Crater, which turned out to be a
Union disaster.
Now, out West.
Where's Sherman? There he is.
Can we see this?
Now, the other major campaign
of the war that of course will
ultimately lead to Union
victory--and I won't get us
quite to the dead-end of the war
today by any means--but it is,
of course, William Sherman's
Atlanta Campaign through
northern Georgia,
the fall of Atlanta by
September of '64.
The campaign lasted all that
summer.
At the same time this stalemate
sets in in Virginia,
around Petersburg,
with these thousands of
casualties.
And you must try to,
if you can imagine Northerners
standing in post offices and
telegraph offices all over the
towns of the Midwest,
New England,
waiting for casualty reports,
and the adjutants of regiments
writing the lists.
Standing in a small town post
office and a telegraph comes
through with a list of the dead;
a dozen, two dozen,
three dozen,
men, from a town that only had
1000 people.
It was beginning to destroy
Northern morale.
And things weren't that much
better in Georgia,
or so it seemed,
throughout that summer.
Sherman finally outmaneuvered
General Joseph Johnston's
Confederate Army,
toward Atlanta,
won at Kennesaw Mountain in two
days in June,
late June of '64,
and essentially put Atlanta
under siege in July and August,
and kept trying to get around,
around, around--especially to
the left, to the east and
south--Atlanta to cut off the
supply lines to this biggest
city in the heartland of the
South.
He finally succeeded,
at great cost,
when Atlanta fell on the 4^(th)
of September in '64.
And the fall of Atlanta is in
some ways, both strategically
and in terms of morale,
one of the most important
little turning points of the
war, that has a huge impact on
the political situation and the
Election of '64 about to
occur--more on that in a second.
It was then that Sherman,
based on this strategy of
conquest, destruction of
resources and war upon people,
made the decision,
really quite quickly,
to launch his march to the sea.
It took him a couple of months
to organize it but from November
15^(th) to Christmas Eve--that's
about five weeks--Sherman's army
marched 285 miles from Atlanta
to Savannah with 62,000 troops.
They were almost unopposed.
General John B.
Hood's Confederate Army,
that had surrendered--in effect
given up--Atlanta,
had retreated south to fight
again.
And Hood's idea,
but actually without Jefferson
Davis's approval--well if
Sherman was going to invade
toward the East,
toward the sea and destroy
Georgia, Hood took an army of
about 30,000 men and invaded
back up into Tennessee,
hoping that Sherman would stop
and come after him.
Sherman said, "Let him go."
It was a kind of a game now,
of time, resources,
destruction,
and who would give up.
"We are not fighting a hostile
army anymore," Sherman said,
I'm quoting him,
"we are fighting a hostile
people.
His aim and objective now was
the civilian population,
and Americans had never made
war on civilians quite like
Sherman would in Georgia.
"We cannot change the hearts of
those people," Sherman wrote of
the South, "but we can make war
so terrible and make them so
sick of war that generations
will pass before they will ever
again appeal to it."
Now up in the Shenandoah
Valley, Philip Sheridan's Union
Army, under similar orders,
to make war on society,
gave a simple order to his
officers;
and most of that army was
cavalry.
His order was put in the
starkest of total war terms.
He said, quote,
"Leave them only their eyes
with which to weep."
This was now savage war.
To win the war with fear was
Sherman's goal,
to win it with destruction and
to win it with maneuvers.
Freed slaves swarmed behind
Sherman's army.
He hated it,
he didn't want them to be
there, he didn't know what to do
with them--what the hell am I
going to do with this people?
First it was 5,000;
10,000; 15.
He had 25 to 30,000 refugee
slaves tailing right behind his
army;
it was about half the size of
his whole army.
Follow that in Doctorow.
Sherman didn't always play
kindness or niceness with them.
At one point his troops lifted
up the pontoon bridge across a
river and scores of freedmen
trying to get across with him
drowned in the river.
Sherman's attitude was "the way
it goes."
They made it by Christmas Eve
to Savannah;
just before that into Liberty
County, just south of Savannah.
And to this day in Liberty
County, Georgia,
there are plenty of people
around--I have a former student
who lives there and runs a
historic site--who will tell
you,
"This is where Sherman turned
left."
Okay.
And you think,
well okay, there must've been a
left turn sign or something,
this is where Sherman turned
left.
I'll also never forget the time
I was doing research in the
Caroliniana Collections in
Columbia,
South Carolina,
and I don't remember exactly
what I asked for in the
Archives--I spent a good week
there--I don't remember.
Oh, it was records about the
state capital and the buildings.
I wanted to know about the
ruins and destruction,
and I asked for this stuff,
and the archivist,
who was a woman,
looked up from the desk at me
and she said,
"Don't have it.
Sherman burnt it."
[Laughter]
Okay, thank you very much,
I won't be able to look at that
stuff apparently.
Now, if you follow the purple
line here, of course,
you realize that this is the
destined,
this is the route of
Sherman's--this is about 280
miles from Atlanta to the sea.
It would give us some of the
best songs of the war,
marching through Georgia.
It also gave the Civil War its
anti-hero, its principal
villain, of Union victory,
some say the architect of total
war--that's a little too much to
lay on Sherman.
But it was now a war of
conquest and destruction.
He did not destroy Savannah but
when he got to Charleston--well
actually much of Charleston he
didn't have to destroy because
it was being destroyed already
by Union gunboats and artillery
from around the harbor.
But the city he did destroy was
Columbia, the capital of South
Carolina, which was burned to
the ground, as,
by the way, was Atlanta.
Now, Sherman would always say
these were just fires that broke
out because of extensive
shelling.
That was not the case in
Columbia.
They burned about everything
that was standing in Columbia,
and then they kept moving
north;
north, north into North
Carolina.
And I'll come back to that
later because the final,
final surrender of the Civil
War, of course,
came in North Carolina,
not in Virginia.
Now, before we get to
Appomattox--I'm going to save
the Siege of Petersburg,
the lifting of the siege and
the march to Appomattox and the
surrender for Thursday,
because it makes a perfect
segway back into wartime
reconstruction plans,
because the nature of that
surrender at Appomattox has a
great deal to do with the kind
of reconstruction ideas and
plans that were boiling as early
as 1863 really,
out of Congress and from
Lincoln himself.
And let me just end with this
little story.
I mentioned that Sherman made
it to the sea at Savannah,
marched part of his troops up
to Charleston,
took Charleston,
the seedbed of Secession and
all of that, although actually
Charleston didn't fully fall to
Union hands until February of
'65.
It had been bombarded
throughout the last eight to
nine months, as I said,
from Union ships and guns all
around the harbor.
And if you've ever been to
Charleston, that glorious,
beautiful colonial city,
that Caribbean city,
as it looks,
with all those mansions about
fifteen to twenty blocks up from
the harbor,
you must imagine it almost
completely in ruin by early
1865.
All the white people evacuated
and abandoned the city,
and the only people left
principally were slaves,
freedmen, thousands of them,
and they in effect took over
the city.
The first Union regiment that
marched up Meeting Street in
Charleston was the 21^(st) USCT,
a colored infantry,
a black regiment,
and they accepted the surrender
of the city from its mayor.
And then they began to hold
ceremonies, the black folks of
Charleston, they began to hold
ceremonies all around the city.
They held a parade in late
March--or was it early April--of
'65.
They had this huge parade where
they had two floats and they
had, on one float,
they had a little slave auction
occurring, a mock slave auction
with a woman with her baby being
sold away,
and on the next float they had
a coffin labeled "Slavery," and
it said "Fort Sumter Dug its
Grave,
April 12^(th), 1861."
And then they planned one more
ceremony, and--oh and by the
way, the war,
when it finally,
finally, finally ended,
they held an extraordinary
ceremony on Fort Sumter.
They crammed about 3000 people
onto the little island.
All kinds of dignitaries came.
Now General Anderson--not the
Colonel who had surrendered the
fort four years ago--came and
raised the U.S.
flag, four years almost to the
day that they had taken it down.
William Lloyd Garrison was
there from the North,
the great abolitionist who wept
uncontrollably when he heard a
small black children's choir
sing John Brown's Body.
And the very night of that
ceremony, which was the 14^(th)
of April,
they held a banquet of a sort
in a building that had a roof on
it, back in Charleston,
and that was the very night,
of course, that Lincoln was
assassinated at Ford's Theater
in Washington.
But the black folks of
Charleston had planned one more
ceremony.
That ceremony was a burial
It turns out that during the
last months of the war the
Confederate Army turned the
planter's horse track,
a racecourse--it was called the
Washington Racecourse--into an
open air cemetery--excuse me,
prison.
And in that open air prison,
in the infield of the horse
track--about 260-odd Union
soldiers had died of disease and
exposure--and they were buried
in unmarked graves in a mass
gravesite out behind the
grandstand of the racetrack.
And by the way,
there was no more important and
symbolic site in low country
planter/slaveholding life then
their racetrack.
Well, the black folks at
Charleston got organized,
they knew about all this.
They went to the site.
They re-interred all the
graves, the men.
They couldn't mark them with
names, they didn't have any
names.
Then they made them proper
graves and they built a fence
all the way around this
cemetery,
about 100 yards long and fity,
sixty yards deep,
and they whitewashed the fence
and over an archway they painted
the inscription "Martyrs of the
Racecourse."
And then on May 1^(st) 1865
they held a parade of 10,000
people, on the racetrack,
led by 3000 black children
carrying armloads of roses and
singing John Brown's
Body,
followed then by black women,
then by black men--it was
regimented this way--then by
contingents of Union infantry.
Everybody marched all the way
around the racetrack;
as many as could fit got into
the gravesite.
Five black preachers read from
scripture.
A children's choir sang the
national anthem,
America the Beautiful,
and several spirituals,
and then they broke from that
and went back into the infield
of the racetrack and did
essentially what you and I do on
Memorial Day,
they ran races,
they listened to sixteen
speeches, by one count,
and the troops marched back and
forth and they held picnics.
This was the first Memorial Day.
African-Americans invented
Memorial Day,
in Charleston,
South Carolina.
There are three or four cities
in the United States,
North and South,
that claim to be the site of
the first Memorial Day,
but they all claim 1866;
they were too late.
I had the great,
blind, good fortune to discover
this story in a messy,
totally disorganized collection
of veterans' papers at the
Houghton Library at Harvard some
years back.
And what you have there is
black Americans,
recently freed from slavery,
announcing to the world,
with their flowers and their
feet and their songs,
what the war had been about.
What they basically were
creating was the Independence
Day of a second American
Revolution.
That story got lost,
it got lost for more than a
century.
And when I discovered it,
I started calling people in
Charleston that I knew in
archives and libraries,
including the Avery Institute,
the black research center in
Charleston--"Has anybody,
have you ever heard of this
story?"
And no one had ever heard it.
It showed the power of the Lost
Cause in the wake of the war to
erase a story.
But I started looking for other
sources, and lo and behold there
were lots of sources.
Harper's Weekly even had
a drawing of the cemetery in an
1867 issue.
The old oval of that racetrack
is still there today.
If you ever go to Charleston go
up to Hampton Park.
Hampton Park is today what the
racecourse was then.
It's named for Wade Hampton,
the white supremacist,
redeemer, and governor of South
Carolina at the end of
Reconstruction and a Confederate
General during the Civil War.
And that park sits immediately
adjacent to the Citadel,
the Military Academy of
Charleston.
On any given day you can see at
any given time about 100 or 200
Citadel cadets jogging on the
track of the old racecourse.
There is no marker,
there's no memento,
there's only a little bit of a
memory.
Although a few years ago a
friend of mine in Charleston
organized a mock ceremony where
we re-enacted that event,
including the children's choir,
and they made me dress up in a
top hat and a funny old
nineteenth century suit and made
me get up on a podium and make a
stupid speech.
But there is an effort,
at least today,
to declare Hampton Park a
National Historic Landmark.
See you Thursday.